um good afternoon my name is Jin tae
ding I'm forming the business Cincinnati
I'll talk about a much very pop key
cryptography and this criminalizes first
of course I'm like to thank the
organizer for the opportunity to speak
here and I all start with the basically
introductions about postponing
cryptography and multivariate
cryptography here actually I will
introduce the concrete scheme the oil
vinegar scheme and to explain to you how
things work then I will talk about
containers tools and then I will talk
about content Act in particular our
reason to work on using edges GL solving
multivariate equations and this is
related to the talk given by Andres and
yesterday and we have a total different
approach to show that the new algorithm
of Gao doesn't work so hopefully I can
expand it in detail how it works so
let's look at what we are doing here of
course here almost all the topic is
relate to a post quantum cryptography
what we want is a built new public key
cryptosystems that can resist quantum
computer attacks as we all know right
now and we have a missed call going on
and we're now in the second round and
this call probably not everybody know
that among all the motive among all the
schemes we have of course CEM schemes
and signature schemes they are right now
in the second round there are nine
signature schemes among nine demand for
them actually are motivated signatures
okay
in general multiple signatures has some
interesting property for example they
have very shortened the signature like a
rainbow has a signature of a size 48
byte and they're very fast internal
computation internet verification but it
has a relatively large public key size
tens have a kilobyte of course MDS is
slightly different so that's the topic
I'm going to cover today and of course I
should first explain what is a digital
signature so digital signature just like
I say and ECC has private key and public
key the public key is used to
verification to verify the signature is
legitimate okay and the private key used
to sign okay this is used broadly on the
network for authentication purpose
yeah and let's look at a multi very
signature schemes okay so in the case of
multi very secure schemes in general the
public key is given by a set of a
multivariate polynomials for example
here is P 1 X 1 to X n 2 p.m.
X 1 to X n okay so each of them is a
motivated promeo over final field and
private key normally is a way to compute
the P inverse to sign you apply P
inverse and to apply a to verify you
apply P
so that's how the basic things works
meaning when you were if I you just plug
in the values of the x1 to xn and then
make sure this is equal if you equal you
accept otherwise you reject yeah and the
security principle of this whole scheme
is based on the fact that solving a set
of motivates equation in general is a
very hard problem
so it's an np-hard hard problem if all
the coefficients are given uniformly
randomly ok so this is a basic security
assumption yeah and let's look at the
quickly the history about some equations
so we can solve single variable to a
degree 2 equation may be fifty thirty
five hundred years ago and then we move
pretty slowly around 1500 we can solve
degree four degrees three equations and
of course afterwards of course we
stopped yeah I internal multivariate
systems and the first algorithms given
by Booker book in 1960s and the idea of
a Booker book was already explained in
the hidden archives organ Harvard before
but he didn't it he was not interesting
communic in computation so it was not
much developed yeah and for the single
very because as I said once you should
degree five we're finished yeah we can
we don't have a formula to solve it and
then Newton better come in to solve the
continuing system and then later for a
single variable over final field you
have below comes algorithm which depends
on the degree of the polynomial which
means you can solve low degree system
not high degree system for multivariate
case in general as we know it is very
hard problem
okay because we can prove it and become
pretty important yeah
and in the case of design of motivated
popke crypto system the fundamental idea
was proposed by different hell earlier
their many attempts and so on but in
terment design principle
our fundamental idea is that we would
like use quadratic system not higher
degree system because a key size problem
and efficiency problem on the other hand
there is a mathematical principle we
should rely on we know solving a high
degree equation I can always reduce it
to solve a low degree equation up to
degree - of course
for example this system x1 times x2
times x3 equal to 5 I can always convert
into x1 times x2 equal to Y and then Y
time x3 equal to 5 so you become degree
2 yeah of course this in this case it
increases the number of variables yeah
and there's a very interesting point of
view given by DV in Paris actually in
2000 some some time in 2000 he said you
know I say use number theory this is a
mathematical in 18th century ECC use
theory of elliptic curves and this is
more than mathematical in 19th century
in the case of multivariate property
cryptosystem we're using theory of
polynomials which is a mathematical
algebra geometry and this is Siri with
Eve love in the 20th century so this is
a prophetic book for mathematic point V
okay so now I look at a simple example I
would like to present to you so this is
an oil vinegar scheme and the rainbow
scheme I mentioned earlier is based on
this one also later I also mentioned air
UV which is also secondly rounded
candidates also based on this one so
this scheme was introduced by Patrick in
1997 ok it's very interesting what the
pattern did so putter run defeat a
system called mouse model my system and
the method he used is called
linearization attack so what he did
essentially is converting attack method
into a mess of designing a signature
schemes okay so in the design the public
key is given by a composition of two
Macs
this is a little bit like is a okay so
you have two maps F and T T is a linear
transformation is a random linear
transformation and F is a nonlinear
polynomial system that you can compute
inverse easily okay so now let me
present an F okay so in the system f you
have two sets of variables X 1 2 X 0 and
X 1 prime to X V Prime
so you have two sets of variables
then you have all polynomials they are
all quadratic and each of them are given
in the following form as I wrote here
summation of a IJ K X I XJ prime
summation bi JK X I prime XJ prime and
the summation of CI k x I as summation D
ikx I prime plus ek and those
polynomials are called or vinegar
polynomials okay this is coming from
pattern if you look at carefully the
reason we call the oil vinegar Pournami
is because there's term missing which is
the correlation coming from or is
missing there are only or vinegar terms
vinegar in vinegar terms but no or your
oil terms that's the basic idea
I'm in principle you can also understand
as system as some kind of perturbation
of an immune system you will see easily
how it works okay so this is the basic
idea of F now I would like to talk about
how to invert to F of course to sign you
I suppose invert the public key map P
inverse I'm since P is a composition of
two maps here I would like to emphasize
by inverse I'm not talking about a
strict mathematics because those maps
are not by ejective this is a subjective
map therefore by English I mean find one
per image okay and let's look at here
then so so if you want to invert P
inverse then if since is a composition
of two maps you can just invert it
individually each of them and things T
is in India so it's very easy it's an
invert of linear map and the key point
how to inverse F inverse okay so the
idea is very simple so suppose if we
give you values of f equal to y 1 to y
ou what I would do is randomly guess the
value of x 1 Prime 2 X V Prime meaning
what I assign random values to vinegar
schemes a vinegar variables so if you do
that
if you do that you can see that this
become constant term this is become
constant the left over this is an image
so therefore the left over is an in-ear
system and is exactly has all variables
and own in the equations and then you
solve the Nina system
and you find a pre-image so that's how
it works it's super simple okay so this
is the famous or even ism and this is a
design in 1997
so more than 23 years ago the basic
design stands okay yeah I hope it is
clear is any question yeah so this is
this is computer and easily you just
there's an Indian map and then you would
ask me the question why do it compose by
this linear map here in the public key
here why do you do that yeah why do you
compose a linear map here the F is oil
vinegar form the reason you want to
compose by effect the T is because you
want to mix oil vinegar together so you
cannot tell who is or who is vinegar
if you leave F alone you can easily tell
what Sawyer who a vinegar and that's the
fundamental reason you apply this linear
transformation and this is essentially a
change of basis okay so that's it this
is the famous ome [ __ ] a signature
scheme and you can see also very easily
that the signing process is very fast
what do you do you just what you just
plug in the values you calculate value
and then you solve an in your system so
therefore essentially you just solve a
linear system and that's the exciting
process that's the most expensive part
of a signing process that's why or
vinegar system is a very efficient
system okay very simple very easy yeah
so I just give a toy example here for
example you can create in the case of
parameter of course this is not a bet
good the parameters over V equal to
suppose choose any consists six you can
choose F seven you can see I have X 1 X
3 X 2 X 3 X 2 X 4 and so on but I don't
have what here so all so let's see oh is
so here there's no X 1 X 2 term ok
there's no X 1 X 2 times 0 is X 1 X 2
okay so the oil vinegar they do not mix
ok so that's the basic idea and if you
plug in values and you can easily
compute the public key okay so I do a
run the linear transformation and
compose it that's essentially mix
everything so afterwards you cannot tell
who is
host vinegar okay so it appears to be
random okay and now let's look at
security okay this is a men topic of
this conference so security and once
when it was designed in 1997 and the
original design is chosen parameter V
equal to O this was defeated by Qibla
shamea using what is called invariant
subspace method so that was a pretty
easy way to do okay and so therefore it
do we realize you have to make V bigger
than door but we also know if it shows
v2 much bigger than oh this is not good
because we have a very nice way to solve
highly highly under defined polynomial
systems okay and what is optimal choice
what we believe is V equal to 200 or 300
K and then from the point of view the
crypt analysis you can attack the system
directly meaning a signature is nothing
but a solution to the equation so
therefore you just solve the system so
we do experiment on small scale that I
could quickly do and you can see that
the system the solving process behaves
exactly the same and a random system you
cannot tell the difference okay and
there's another very interesting
sanctity bubble recent later a entire
one by a young one etc and this one is
just find a way to directly computer
keys okay it turns out this method again
leads to a polynomial system again a
quadratic polynomial system so therefore
to invert the system to find the secret
key is again some upon the newest system
and if you look at this system
you realize this is miss very strange
meaning the signature is three or four
times the size of hash
okay so what we did in 2004 was detach
MIT we proposed what is called a rainbow
scheme okay so this is one of the second
around candidates in the NIST
standardization process and this in this
case the system is slightly more
complicated in a sense that we compose
not only one linear factors we actually
compose tuning effectors so s and T and
middle F is essentially a milling system
but
stack it Oh a Millikan system which
means I have one label or a vinegar and
the top of that I appeared another or
your vinegar and the reason we do this
is because what we want to increase the
efficiency so reduce the key size reduce
the signature size and make system more
efficient okay but because of this new
design there's a new way to attack a
system called a mean rank okay so what
is the mean right mean rank is a problem
you find an email combination of a set
of measures to achieve the minimum rank
of the set of matrices
okay so there's another way to attack
this new system so this is a we have to
take into consideration in choosing the
parameters okay
and there's another very interesting
scheme I call our UV this was also in
the second to run submission and they
had they present a very interesting idea
so this is a purely or a vinegar scheme
except okay except is that what they did
is what they did is that you choose so
you are trying something on a large
field but you choose all the
coefficients in F and T in the GF - okay
yeah you choose everything over GF 2
here everything here nevertheless when
you sign you sign a bigger document
meaning you sign documents over larger
field and this is called air UV which
means that lift the UV okay
the main purpose again is shorten the
size of a public key because the public
key of multi-record isms are relative
large however we find a new way to break
it last year we caught a substantial
subfield differential attack and this
attack again is reduced a way to solve
quadratic polynomial systems that's how
we defeat it okay this is Lu movie and
if you look at all the work I've done in
terms of attacks are multivariate
schemes so there's this the one way to
do direct attack which means you just
solve the system you put a you put a
document there and you try to find the
solution or find the key this is a risk
cancellation attack or mere an attack or
sub prevention as a software different
attack
but the key point is that all this
attack method in the end reduce the
problem to a problems of a set of
motivate polynomial system of a finite
field all of them all the message as
before as far we know is a problem of
solving multiplying a polynomial systems
so now I will move on to something
multiply polynomials so injurer a
motivating system are given by F 1 equal
to I 1 and so on we want to find a
solution by for mathematic V you will
look at the instead of this system we
are look at F 1 minus y 1 equal to 0 and
blah blah equal to 0 ok from the point
of view of cryptography normally we are
trying to find the keys which mean the
solutions unique okay and in general
what we should know is so in this system
is essentially study over the what we
call the function ring over this
variables x1 to xn okay and the key
point is that if the solution is unique
and if you add those field equation
inside there the ideal generated by this
set of polynomials is actually the same
ideal generated by X I minus AI ok ok so
that's the key observation okay then
let's look at the way to solve a
polynomial system so the first general
method is a groma based method I
mentioned it earlier it evolved in 1960s
ok
and their idea is what uses what is
called s polynomial and this is coming
from the leading terms ok so basically
what we try to do is build a nice basis
for the idea or generate by f1 minus y1
and FM minus M by M ok and then in this
case you are dealing with individual
polynomials and then you do reduction
okay and then then later not realize
that it is not a good idea to do
reduction individually instead we may be
sure to use linear algebra method to do
the reduction simultaneously so the neat
dense linear algebra method was
introduced okay so how do we do this so
what we are do is what we are again
instead looking at instead of looking at
it
Esper
what we think is just think in term of
the whole idea which means I'm looking
at ideal generated by this polynomial
systems again let me repeat right sinks
I know the solution is unique so
therefore I know this element X I - AI
is inside the idea which means I can do
linear combinations of elements like
that to arrive to derive this linear
polynomial is X I - yeah once I find
that I find a solution okay and here I
would emphasize the importance of the
field the equation so if you don't
include a field equation from
mathematical perspective you are not so
we evolve it find a field instead of you
are solving the algebraic closure
therefore there are tons of solutions
for the system in general so therefore
you must include a few the equation to
solve the system okay so what is the
computation strategy then okay the
competition strategy in the end is very
simple okay
instead of looking the polynomial as a
just polynomials what we do is we build
a huge matrix system okay in the matrix
system each column represents a monomial
and each row represents a polynomial and
what you do is do you do Gaussian nation
and eliminate all the high degree terms
and the leftover is in linear terms and
then you find the solution for the
system that's how it works so therefore
the complexity complete depends on the
size of the matrices you have to deal
with okay so this is the so called XL
hours okay this is a done by Lizotte
okay first proposed by him okay and
let's get a look at picture design okay
so how do you do this so you ask me
solve this system F 1 to F n equal to 0
what I do is I multiply F each of them
by a degree one polynomial and then
collect them and do gosh emulation if I
find any new terms I'm done if not I go
to degree three
I'll go to degree 4 and you go higher we
know from the from what I explained
about idea we know this in the end will
generate the whole idea that means in
the end you will find X I minus AI
therefore you find the solution of
course for our perspective we want what
we want a degree to go as low as a
puzzle but because the
a degree you go they've come at the
higher complexity you have okay so this
is the idea okay so more Malia what you
do you climb up slowly and then try to
what to go as well as possible so this
is a the basic idea okay but if you look
at the strategy you realize I have start
with a high degree polynomial in the end
I want to go to a low degree point which
means what the system must generate
somehow which means all the high degree
turn come it has to be canceled out okay
and this mic has developed something
called the mutant a mutant is a product
coming from sometime in general coming
from a degree for and usually you can
use mutant to speed other computation
okay so what is ideal mutant the me on
Yemen is very simple so you climb up
Kalama each time you do computations you
want to make sure there's no new low
degree polynomial produced if we produce
new polynomial this are called mutants
because you are going higher and then
produce a low poll numbers and this low
degree polymer you must multiply them up
to the level you were before you go
higher so that's the idea of the mutant
and I will so I will not go over the
details but the most important thing is
that in general because we used we're
using matrix method okay
in general the degree the highest degree
at which you have to deal with decides
the size of the matrix
okay that's decide the complexity okay
and the mutant degree is that first is
the degree first time you produce a
mutant and the degenerate degree is the
first degree you have a huge error and
non-tribal CCG okay so what is the
relation between those in general are
seven degrees higher than mutant degree
than the degeneration degree okay but if
you do experiment you general find out
in general this what it's two degrees
are very close okay in German okay the
less equal to and this is a basis of
estimated complexity of solving
polynomial system okay and then later
and by gamma and I think French name I
forgot his name did define something
called a degree of regularity and we
generalize it and then at the moment we
actually can do very good as
the degree of a rarity which decides the
complexity of solving polynomial systems
and this give us the confidence to
design the concrete parameters for
multivariate systems okay
so one thing I would like to emphasize
very much is that in general our theory
and experimental
meaning if you give me a polymer system
we can estimate the complexity and if
you do experiment they match very well
okay and that allow us to choose optimal
choice of parameters okay and now I
would like to turn it about sparsity
okay this is I we used later and if you
look at this XA algorithm okay
instead of going step by step going up
you just go one way all the way to a
highest degree and then what you deal
with are each pond over just multiply a
monomial
which means in each row the number of a
term is fixed because here only
multiplied by a single monomial and that
means you are dealing with a sparse
polynomial system and that allows you
use a new type in linear algebra method
for example boyoung who is here and they
develop a using method of Whitman to
speed at a competition of summing Excel
system so in this case it happens very
often even though you have a very large
matrix but you can actually do much
faster because a speed-up come from
Whitman okay so this is classical
solving method okay now I would like to
talk a little bit about quantum of
course the first attack should come in
from a global equity okay I think there
are a few papers written on it and I
don't want to talk too much detail about
it and the important of this work is
estimate how many qubits you need to
attack and since the quadratus ism has a
lot of a monomial so therefore the
number of qubits is relatively large and
of course the speed-up is square root
speed-up okay but today most of time I
want to spend more time talking about
the wobble reason to work I'm using
agile relate to as ratio and
application to solving motivated
eponymous system so extra gel is our and
developed by I think ice so and let's
talk about it already I just repeat what
he said so the estrogen I was about by
Harrow hasidim and the noid in 2009 okay
and this method is to solve sparse
linear system ax equal to B over real
numbers okay and so efficiently doing
this using this algorithm there's quite
a few requirement the example you must
have efficient way to compute or excess
nonzero terms in a which means it's not
enough a is spots you cannot have a
sparse just running it anywhere you have
to behave what very I should be fishing
a way to access it okay from what I know
or maybe Andres tell me something I have
signed a has should be what should be
hermitian okay and then the interesting
thing is the complexity okay the
compressor it depends on the this number
called a condition number K so what is
this number this number is the ratio of
the Max and the minimum eigen value of a
and then the complexity as far as I know
now the best eyes I know long is what D
times K times polynomial log D times K
over epsilon here D is the spots of a if
some is a precision okay it's a
conditional number okay so this is the
actual average which undressed mentioned
that earlier already okay now I'll say
something slightly different what Andres
said okay so what cow and so on did in
2007 2017 okay in cow etc in 2017 here's
a new paper what they did is apply at ul
to excel they want to use Ezreal to
speed up polynomial solving system okay
a key method used is how to convert a
system over GF 2 into a system of real
numbers because atresia L can run only
over real numbers not over GF 2 so in
therefore in general even that phase
armor game that gia
to system FX equals zero you need to add
what two times Z Z is a new variable and
this is the modular part you take an out
only by doing that you what you are
moving form over GF 2 to what two real
numbers ok this idea we already use this
idea in 2012 in our paper we did relate
to lattice and so on but this is not
enough because you're adding new
variable to the system ok we want to add
more constraints to the new variables so
what do we do
and in general since this is over GF 2
you have 1 0 so you add together
therefore we have a way more or less to
what find the range we can find the
range of Z and then we'll impose one
more equation this equation is what Z
minus I you could not a direct product a
product of Z minus I equals 0
where I coming from the range of Z and
put this together ok ok you add this
system and then you apply Excel of
course in this case you must go a much
higher degree ok for GF 2 in general if
you have a random system the degree up
to which you have to go is about zero
point 8 9 9 n ok here you must go higher
our estimate is at least n over 2 ok
this is our estimate ok so now let's see
how God does that so Gao use the orange
journal system and I add this equation
ok and then apply Excel and go up to the
degree at which the solution can be
found and then they try to solve em X
equal to B ok so here very important
thing is that you should notice B also
has in requirements B cannot be just as
randomly as numbers everywhere the B
also can be has to have such a has to
satisfy certain properties but if you
look carefully the system you realize
because you are multiplying polynomials
once you multiply on monomials almost
nobody has constant term except orange
no system so therefore you had inside bu
and most have n what now there are times
there
and there are normally is that one and
is it okay so that's it and then it's
who to come to convert the system into a
hermitian system what do you do you you
multiply our M transpose on the other
side okay and then you transpose apply
to be but you should realize M is mass M
transpose again is pass and Emma turns
about time B again this very spot it's
very easy to argue so in the end what
you use once off is this system and this
term you can easily verify that it
satisfies all the requirements demanded
by a shell so here this is very
important this is a very important part
okay otherwise you're not serving over
real numbers you are summing over GF 2
but as usual can only apply to real
numbers okay and form the formula I gave
you earlier you realize ha the
complexity here more or less what the
sparsity is more the position is because
the solutions are 0 once we don't need a
higher position and what
therefore the complexity complete
depends on this condition number okay
the andres made a very interesting
argument about conditional number and
today i present that to a different one
okay so let's see how we estimate the
completion number before I do that I
would like to know the range of the
numbers Z okay and because it is
quadratic system therefore you expect to
have n square over 2 terms more or less
and then you can argue easily
ascetically on and we did experiment you
can see the range of Z in general is
between minus 8 over n at over N and
here I can show you some graphs my
student did for me and this is this case
of 40 variables and you can see the
range here okay and then this is a 120
and then this is 200 okay so this is
range you can see a pretty easily the
standard deviation is about what the
standard deviation is about and over 8
so that's what I wished proposed choose
a member of 8 okay yeah so this is now
I would like to argue that the algorithm
cannot be applied as efficient as we
claimed
okay again this is a joint work with the
Vlad who is sitting here from Waterloo
okay so what we do is we divide the
linear system into two parts okay
the original system whose computer can
only concern 0 1 minus 1 or 2 and so on
this is the first half and the second
part in of this one ok involve this
polynomial if you look at this point
about this modem it's very interesting
the leading turn of this phone is Z Z to
the basically n over 4 a degree
however the linear term is essentially M
over 8 factorial square so which means
you have a very where you have a leading
term 1 and you have what you have a
constant term okay and the degree 1 term
is what is an Atari the one is to Z to
the power of 8 over and over for ok and
this corresponds to the linear term ok
because the I can be 0 right so
therefore this is a end over 8 factor
that is square and this is definitely
bigger than n square a 2 to the N sorry
be given to them so we divided what the
matrix so given a matrix given a matrix
we divided them into two parts the top
part only involves 0 1 2 minus 1 and
bottom part involved the point number
coming from here which may have one and
then numbers bigger than two today okay
you say what is the problem why this is
a issue okay then if you compute the M
transpose time M okay you realize the
elements so here the zero ones have at
most n square terms n square over two
terms and if you compute the transpose
you're basing to calculate the length of
each vector this roughly what of size n
square over two but the bottom one you
have one term what bigger you could to
to the end therefore what therefore it
should be 2 2 to n so therefore what
diagonal entry of the bottom half are
much bigger than what the ones on the
top half
okay but we know the minimal engine
value is less than the minimum of all
the entries and the maximum angle value
is a bigger than what the largest
entries and therefore what is the ratio
of this to number is bigger than the
conditional number which is a 2 to the
2n should be 2 to the N over and square
over 2 so therefore we think it's
exponential
therefore this new algorithm actually
has exponential complexity so this is
our argument it's very different from
and the rest it ok so this is a what we
argued ok is then something come up we
realize ok meaning you realize this this
I have a huge entries right why don't I
just what divided by a huge number what
makes them all what small the number
doesn't work anymore it's possible right
but we argue you cannot do that why is
that that's problem coming from
precision if you divide by 2 to the N
this number is going to be super small
but we know if you changed it and then
what this system requires very high high
precision as n goes bigger and if you
change the value even slightly you're
actually in somewhat different the
polynomial system so therefore we
believe the scaling cannot be applied in
the sense that stage the system will be
become unstable because error naturally
cost coming from experiments so we argue
that you cannot do so so therefore our
conclusion is the from this analysis is
that Gauss Aggron should not work ok so
this is the work we just finished ok a
few days ago we just finished okay so we
present our argument okay and again I
would like to emphasize yeah this is a
very interesting from the perspective of
the Nemea system is this linear system
is giving us a what big trouble because
this limit of the involve small numbers
and huge numbers so we believe that's
the reason it costs the condition number
to be
exponential they are forward therefore
it cannot be applied okay I think that's
it that's all I intend to talk okay and
thank you very much
[Applause]
no we don't have any proof no I don't
have this not no proof no we don't have
any proof yes that is it so we cannot
there's no distinguished attack either
we should be given a public key we don't
have any way to distinguish the public
key format random consistent we don't
have proper security no we do study
analysis but we don't have we did things
like that
yeah but not proof nope oops yes she did
she did in America and Isis she only
didn't do Mariko
it is this is my understanding yes
I'm no expert in Graebner basis but
could you say a word or two about where
the f-4 algorithm fits into a global
basis is a very good for solving for no
reason right globally you do s pairs s
parental reduction okay but by ingre
basis the case you each time you reduce
one problem at a time
so what the French group did Lazard for
J and so on and they say why don't we do
it with simultaneously so which mean you
have a bunch of polynomial of the same
degrees and what you find all possible
can reduce it than to a Nene algebra
then reduce them all simultaneously okay
so Excel is what Excel is in sometimes
very similar Excel what Xiao trying to
do is what is actually Excel in general
is much less efficient than going
overseas
because once you produce new polymer
immediately use it and so on so Excel
normal equals higher degree then as well
but but if we use sparsity he's with
math and then we have example showing
the extra do better I think I yes so I
think in one problem we really
understand this meringue problem mean
rank problem I so I let me go yes
so in principle I already yes so very
good I you can see that's the attack
method I put it here direct attack okay
returns rate this is also having system
of GF 2 but the in bromine Wang is
slightly different
me rank subsystem Olivia higher and
recently people in list and also I think
the French group also did very nice
attacks improving the mean rank for
example I think the racket design of the
drug design of code based system is
broken because develop in what here on
the problem is a following problem you
are given a set of matrices you wanted a
linear combination this measure to do
and reduce it to the lowest possible
rank that's it yeah we know how low it
can be we actually know that how low it
can be
interesting instance sighs that means
minimum Kinston sighs example lets me
use rainbow fields ample the rank is
around the rank is around the 6064 and
the N is around 96 we should measure so
96 by 96 and that's roughly the over
this is over GF 16 this 1 over 16 yeah
but if you attack the AUV types and it's
over GF 2
that's a nice problem thank you very
much thank you